today's event is a joint effort of the
South Dakota know until Association the
Mitchell NRCS off field office SDSU
Extension and NRCS and one of the first
things I'd like to do is thank all our
sponsors that helped us put together
provide input and money for today's
event
and I'll just read through the list
South Dakota wheat commission Farm
Credit Services of America wheat growers
Mustang Steve Monsanto Fergus Dane seeds
next level an LLC Milbourne seeds
lacrosse seeds Dakota best see a dramedy
plus farmers Alliance Mitchell first
Kona National Bank CMV operations and
Davis of councilman Scott supply crop
tech Ducks Unlimited Aurora County
Conservation District Davidson County
Conservation District Hansa County
Conservation District South Dakota Hotel
Association SDSU Extension USDA and NRCS
and pioneer hi-bred to DuPont so let's
give them all welcome
so Ruth said you've got just a little
bit of time to talk about a lot a lot of
things we're gonna hit a few things real
lightly today Dakota Lakes research
farmers you probably know should know by
now is located east appear along
Missouri River we have both irrigated
and dryland stuff I went back through
all the talks that I've done over the
years here and and kind of looked at
those and and I summarized those real
neatly if you're in this part of the
world you want to take the eeet eeet is
of Apple transpiration you want all the
water to go through plants and and
there's every one of the speakers so far
today has talked about the idea is to
get plants growing roots in the ground
those kind of things we want to match my
snow catch that's one of the things we
want to do we want to get some vertical
architecture up there you got to decide
which information sources you can trust
there's a lot of people try to tell you
a lot of things especially when it comes
to cover crops and stuff some of them
don't really know what they're talking
about so decide which one of those that
you can trust and this are listening to
them address the problem stead of
treating the symptom you know we we
talked about water hemp John bee I'd
just shortly go or the reason they got a
hot water hemp in the eastern part of
the United States they don't have enough
diversity and they don't have enough
cover and whatever so they have water
hemp they have resistant weeds let's go
back and fix it I always like to pick on
NRCS because they had you guys building
a lot of terraces terraces don't make
the water go in the ground so that water
infiltration kit that they're handing
out here that would have told you water
doesn't go in the ground just putting a
ditch up there to keep from running out
of the field doesn't really make the
crop grow better ideas make the water go
in the ground and no-till does that
cover crops can help us do that to a
certain extent mother nature's an
opportunist if you have a problem you've
created the opportunity
so if you've got a weed or disease or an
insect or anything happening someplace
in the way you designed your system
you've created that opportunity because
Mother Nature will come in and and fill
that in I see Darrell's here so Darrell
Dennehy is sitting back there but years
and years ago we were when they first
came out with at that kind of time they
called it Emmy corn pursuit tolerant
corn and I had a young producer in Sioux
Falls tell me don't have to worry about
crop rotation because I got pursuit corn
and pursuit beans and I can just use
pursuit and I won't have any reason any
any problems and I said well you're
gonna have resistant weeds in Cyanamid
at the time took umbrage with me saying
that because there was no proof that
there was going to be resistant weeds I
think also said they'd be cross
resistance other ALS herbicides and they
wanted to retraction and all we did is
Leon and Darryl come out and put in a
trial for me and I went up to my
neighbors and found some I don't know if
you knew I went and done that found some
found some glean tolerant kocha weeds
and shook it around overtop of that
trial and voila we had our proof stripes
Bruce a crop which is healthy not a crop
that does not get sick so remember that
too we we spent a lot of time trying to
treat things that are getting sick land
we should really just be trying to make
sure we we keep it healthy so that
really takes a whole system and you guys
have all seen that if you can oh and the
only one thing about a soil what
parameter would you want to know and J
furie hit this a bit today I'm going to
hit it harder within all textural groups
as organic matter increased from one to
three percent available water holding
capacity doubled on organic matter
content increase to four percent have
been accounted for more than 60% of
available water holding capacity in the
Red River Valley
they have salinity and water logging
problems because their water doesn't
hold as much soil doesn't hold as much
water as it should we have the same
problem here our soils no longer hold as
much water they used to hold this much
water
now they'll hold this much water so when
we get a little bit of rain they're
waterlogged then we get saline
seats will get waterlogging whatever if
we had deeper soils in terms of water
holding capacity then we could hold more
water we wouldn't get wet waterlogged
early we wouldn't get dry late and we
wouldn't have as much problem with
salinity when organic matter contents
increased four percent and then
accounted for more than 60% of the
available water holding capacity when
soil water storage capacity is low much
of the rain that falls during extended
periods of precipitation is lost in
contrast highest water storage capacity
combined with effective capture of rain
by making the water go on the ground and
snowmelt over the fall winter and spring
can support a crop to extend the dry
periods and what we're trying to do with
cover crops and they don't have as big a
fit here as they do in Illinois where
they have in Indiana where they have
longer growing seasons and more rain but
we have opportunities here what we're
trying to do is take these cool periods
of these of the year or these odd
periods of the year and build organic
matter and suppress weeds and do some of
those things and and we only do that
when we have the opportunity short term
studies are not accurate and evaluating
treatments I was impressed that John was
showing us 20-some years of treatments
that's very very rare anymore and we do
that at Dakota lakes but not very many
people do that
a farmer manages ecosystems you take
sunlight water and carbon dioxide and
make them into products to be sold
that's your business you're capturing
sunlight and if you're only growing corn
and soybeans you're capturing just a
very small percentage of the sunlight
every year let's capture more sunlight
because what the energy from the
sunlight that goes into the soil or
whatever that's the stuff that drives
that whole ecosystem crop rotations
allow for time for natural enemies to
destroy the pathogen the one crop well
unrelated crops are growing and we spend
our whole career working on crop
rotation proper intensity adequate
diversity
and then we're stable in proper
intensity is is matching that natural
water cycle native vegetation is the
best way to tell what you can do as I
travel around the world the first thing
I do is look at the native vegetation
and Jake can tell you that that's one of
the things he does too
right you look at the native vegetation
that integrates the soil characteristics
the climate including rainfall and
temperatures and those kind of things
that integrates them all into one
package people weigh how much rainfall
you get it's air out it's relative
Amarillo Texas Pierre South Dakota and
Brandon Manitoba get exactly the same
rainfall Amarillo Texas is a desert
Pierre South Dakota is a Prairie Brandon
Manitoba is what they call a parkland
which is trees and tall grass prairie
same amount of rainfall different
temperatures different amounts of heat
organic matter is important when we take
off stuff somebody start talking about
hey today and that was about ready to go
crazy in the back of the room if you
take off a 75 bushel a cur wheat crop or
half of a 150 bushel acre corn crop you
take off 100 pounds again I mean 50
pounds and five pounds of P 100 pounds
of K and three thousand pounds of carbon
your mining one unit train of soybeans
these nice circle tracts 110 cars one
unit training the soybeans has four
hundred thousand pounds of phosphorus if
we keep shipping that stuff out we're
mining because the Chinese aren't
sending it back okay so in what happened
do we do that for a hundred years we
won't have any soils left and JRE told
you and they don't have any soils left
in the Red River Valley so they're
putting in drain tile to get rid of that
excess water so we can get
Lake Winnipeg and screw-up Lake Winnipeg
right matching water used to the climate
and soils is imperative okay
matching water use to what you have most
of the plant growth problems blamed with
no tillers other than adequate diversity
and proper intensity or errors in
technique no reason for errors in
technique anymore we've got good
equipment so let's get our diversity
intensity rate in you an environment
Sawgrass Prairie or wetter the goal
should be to have something growing at
all times that's this area in East
should have something growing at all
times that's going to require the use of
cover crops or forage double crops
because you can't really do two grain
crops in a year there's not enough time
okay subhuman semi-arid Pierre South
Dakota arid environments cover crops can
be utilized to increase organic matter
and biological activity we're going to
use them less frequently because we
don't have the moisture cover crops are
like tillage in wet environments more
and longer covered forage periods are
needed in drier environments residue
loss can be an issue if the wrong
species are chosen lots of emphasis on
some people using radishes turnips and
and and rapeseed and those kind of
things those are brassicas they get rid
of residue you're going to be to bear to
fast as you get drier you got to really
limit how many of those you put in there
okay number one decide what you want to
do before trying to choose a cover crop
John said this you know he said it
several times guy right for me I wanted
I want to tell you that John Pike seed
company that family seed company went
away
the back seed company he mentioned is
still there
no damn relatives of mine mine all got
hung for horse Steven but I thought I
should throw that in there
think of your cover crop of just another
component of your rotation it's not
separate you got to know what you're
gonna do right using a mixture of cover
crops allows meeting several goals
simultaneously mixers add more diversity
grow at different times better compete
with weeds optimize nutrient cycling etc
but be careful not to bridge diseases or
insects choose your mix carefully got a
call from a major cover crop seed
suppliers and one of my growers said
that his soybeans behind cover crop did
not yield as good as his soybeans where
he didn't have a cover crop because he
had fight tatra I said what did you have
in the cover crop map so who have just
our normal 12 Way mix as well give me
here's a list soybeans we're in that
list ah don't do that but now in the old
days the Jim River Valley here in north
when when guys were gonna grow soybeans
for the first time 25 30 years ago 25
years ago or more I'd say okay go after
wheat and plant some soybeans as a cover
crop after the wheat before you put the
soybeans in the next spring because you
need to prime that right so be a pump
get some rhizobian ocula out there
otherwise you'll never be as good that's
first time don't do that again for again
okay so think about what you're trying
to do creating conditions beneficial for
the next crop is one of the goals water
and nutrient management another primary
goal water use by a cover crop during
the nine crop period can often be
regained during the growing season
because of better infiltration reduce
runoff improve water relations more
cover more cover if you do it right
remember I talked about the brass
here's the thing that Jason Miller and I
did I had a this is back in 2008 I had a
winter wheat cornfield P rotation
there's a wheat stubble no cover crop
this is on the 9th of July we still had
this total cover to stop the e from the
soil back up back up here's right next
to it
we had a rotation had actually more
cover spring lee winter wheat corn but
we put a Braska cover crop in there
it's almost bare I think it was about 20
bushel difference because we lost the
residue ok understand your rainfall
patterns for your area and the water
holding capacity of your soils in order
to plan how you're going to do this and
use web soil survey here's one of my
soils we farmed some West River stuff we
got Jim Finley used to be one of my
board guys he can tell you about that we
if I take a web soil survey there is my
north unit ok this is five miles north
of the farm this is a promised soil in
opal soil the glacier went around here
this is the old ocean bottom this is a
West River pure shale derived soil that
field right here is Jimmy corals bucking
horse pasture you really never have
lived until you have a rodeo contractor
as a neighbor
ok comes Cadillac windows down goes see
any horses yep
how many
about 120 how long ago
Oh about an hour-and-a-half hmm weird to
go that way
Thanks so what this means is this you
can get all kinds of stuff off web soil
survey and if you don't know how to use
that you need to get it and get an app
on your phone I can tell you what's oil
used to be here before they built a
building talk to your NRCS people what
this says is this somewhere between five
no three and six and a half inches of
total available water on this spot that
heavy soil does not hold very much
available water I manage that soil is
very heavy clay I manage that much
different than I do
my main farm here's a little gate
glacial tongue that comes out there okay
that one holds about seven inches okay
these opals up in here hold less than
three because they're only about this
deep to shave here's the main farm
here's my good Lowery's right those are
more like you guys have you can see I
got some of the red ones and those and
whatever but these will hold about ten
inches a lot I managed that differently
than something that holds five so once I
know how much my bucket holds then I go
get my rainfall this is Mitchell and
I've got a I've got a I've got an Excel
spreadsheet that'll do this for you got
every rainfall from every station in the
state of South Dakota and you can do
this type of thing for you so I start
from October to October and you'll
precip Mitchell twenty two point zero
six or eight six this is from a few
years ago so now everybody's going well
we get more rainfall now okay well
that's fine
so we're going to look at what happens
when you didn't get as much rainfall
take the out of thee T from July to June
from when you would harvest wheat until
you would need water for your core
corn defusing water before June you get
nineteen point three four inches of rain
how much is the soil hold seven ten
maybe twelve if it was totally dry when
you harvested the wheat which it
normally isn't totally dried to four
feet when you harvested the wheat you
hold ten or twelve you got trying to put
19 inches of water in there and guys say
I don't want a no-till hit too damn wet
in the spring what a wonderful problem
to have if you live in South Dakota hey
come on so let's turn that into an
opportunity and that's where you have a
chance to do something if you go wheat
to sunflowers it's 22 inches but that's
the type of you plant peas and grow
wheat that yeah at 22 inches if I'm
backing up one if you get half a normal
which we seldom do it's still 9 inches
almost 10 inches if you get half a
normal and you keep taking the EIT 80
and have it done tillage and you make
the water go in the ground and do all
those things you're supposed to do
you're going to fill a soil up at half
of normal so you're always going to be
too wet
okay that's why you grow good weed after
peas okay
and from October to June 1st of October
1st of June from corn to sunflowers 12.1
you're still going to fill the soil up
if you've got good cover take the out
eet that kind of stuff right so 1/2 a
normal six point zero six when we first
told guys at Gettysburg and Pierre they
should put their sunflowers into corn
they thought it was stark raving mad now
if you drive from Blount to Gettysburg
they're all got their sunflowers in the
corn because you got to do the numbers
July to November this is your
opportunity fall cover crop July to
November 8.34
that other one was 19 if you use that 8
you're still going to have enough to
fill that soil by the time corn needs it
if you're doing all the things we talked
about and you keep the cover and you do
that kind of stuff right
even in half a normal yet four that's
enough
you can use that you'll see you're going
to have enough to get your corn started
the next year July to September when you
harvest your wheat to when you appease
it to where you do winter wheat there's
not enough time there not enough water
to try to do a cover crop on dry land we
will do this with irrigation the old
long fallow you guys all look at me I
grew up 60 miles from here we did long
fallow on a half section of ground
because the landlord wanted that wheat
Milo long fallow we had saline seeps
god-awful mess in there and I had no
idea when I got older and got a little
more educated I goat cheese thought it's
stupid damn thing to do right now they
farm it the way they should and they
don't have the Saline seat problem cover
crop seeds need to be in expensive in
terms of cost per acre small seeds means
less volume you know we we look on our
shed but be careful to not do peas as
cover crops of you doing peas someplace
in the rotation you'd like to have about
a six year break between pea crops to
not get root diseases or lentils some of
these crops you've got to be careful
with small seeds grow better on the
surface and larger seeds large seeds
emerge better through a matter residue
mixing large and small seeds in the same
trench helps the large seeds help the
small seeds emerge better they kind of
break the path using harrows to improve
the stand of surface pride cast seed
improves the stand of weeds as well and
it makes your residue go away right
not not one of the things you like to do
one important goal is to use it the
cover crop to balance the diet of the
soil organisms run elverson was asking
some questions before about how do I you
know shouldn't I add more carbon and
whatever and I'm sitting back there with
him saying well Ron maybe that's put
some cover crops in and up up your
nitrogen and carbon but have a higher
proportion and if you want to get more
in in the system to balance your high
carbon so that's kind of what you do
with that thing it's kind of like
feeding cows is you want you don't feed
a cow straight straw she needs to have
some protein the trouble with feeding
the cows straight straw it's you just
can't eat enough of it because you can't
digest it hey it's not good food for so
you got to give her a little protein and
then that makes it good food
so that's thing managing cover crops is
more of an art than a science at this
point if anybody tells you they know how
to do it they're a liar I mean it's just
really more of an art if at least some
component of a rotation to not feeling
excessively dry year John was talking
about 2012 if you didn't fail in 2012
with some of your components we
harvested really good winter wheat in
2012 but the corn sucked okay but if
some of those components don't fail then
you don't have enough intensity nobody
everybody wants to have a rotation that
doesn't fail when it's dry but if you
don't fail when it's really dry like
that you haven't taken full advantage of
a normal year and you will fail badly in
wet years and this is what's happened to
a lot of people they've been overly
cautious and then they failed because
it's too wet if you look at a guy that
still does wheat summer fallows in
Montana couple weeks ago they still do
we thumb fallow there
for hey boo do ya
pH is a five because they're leaching
all the lime out the limes at 3 foot and
then they're telling put lime on the top
because they put all their lying down
below I mean like get some roots out
there bring the stuff from pool back to
the surface we're blonde but I just said
to them guys 9 years out of town you
fail because you followed that ground
and you could have done something with
it you've failed 9 years out of 10 when
gets Homer fella so take about water
cycle energy flow mineral cycle
community dynamics ok mineral cycler the
nutrients available for plant use or
have they been leached eroded or
transported from the landscape
ecosystems the leak nutrients become
deserts one of those nutrients is carbon
k talked about losing carbon gaining
carbon losing carbon gaining carbon if
we keep losing carbon we're going to
turn into a desert as these e good good
students saline seeps indicate leakage
decreasing pH indicates leaking one unit
rain soybeans almost half a million
pounds so saline seep brain here goes
here we've got to get this cycle fix
here truly a water cycling issue
I call this catch and release nutrients
what's in the saline sea salt I used to
teach chemistry there's lots of salts
right every to take an acid the base to
make a salt so salt isn't an answer
number one thing that's in the saline
seep is nitrate that's fertilizer number
two thing that's in there's calcium
sulfate that's gypsum that's a
fertilizer number three thing that's in
there is calcium carbonate that's lime
that's a fertilizer so when I asked you
that question you're supposed to say
fertilizer okay so all the kids from
SCSU and all the kids from water tell
them to come and visit I got two
instructors trained then I asked those
kids that class and they'll go
because if they don't say that then I
yell at the instructor if you get
stranded in the rain the back forty
drive home across the tilled field or
the pastor pastor people say oh I get
you know by no-till is too wet and I get
stuck it's not no tills fault you
haven't got the soil structure there yet
and you haven't got your water cycle
fixed organic matter makes a difference
we've been running some rotations that
read at Pier 4 since 1990 here's some
winter wheat 2006 it doesn't look very
good right across the road it looks like
this what's the difference well if I
look at those two fields this is a good
one
this is a bad one both of them are
winter wheat that followed peas that
followed corn this rotation is identical
except I've got an extra soybean in
there
soybeans are low and carbon peas are low
in carbon wheat and corn or high in
carbon so one of those I got two-thirds
high carbon one third low and the other
ones half-and-half corn soybeans
half-and-half you don't have enough
carbon unless you add some carbons from
other place so what's that mean for
yields with seven point nine inches of
rain or total coal preset between when
the peas harvested and the wheat was
harvested and seven point nine inches in
2006 sixty versus twenty nine twenty
three point seven in 2005 92 versus
fifty-seven six point four and two two
thousand two fifty six verses twenty
eight organic matter makes a difference
but you kind of had to be there for a
few years and we John showed that - hey
takes a little while to restore those
soils because they've been degraded it
wasn't our fault
but we're fixing them if you if you get
a chance watch the Cronin farms video
Leopold video mics as well
grandpa broke this land and my dad mind
the land and it's up to Monty and I fix
it right
okay that's it's up to us to fix it this
year
okay here's that two-thirds high residue
ninety-five bushel thirteen four here's
that half eighty here's another half
with Cara nada instead of piece sixty
here's where I got even higher carbon
count content ninety-five and
eighty-seven organic matter makes a
difference alternate year week this is
old data from 1990s every other year
wheat half high residue half low residue
forty six bushel two years high and one
year at old fifty-three here I got two
years a wheat one your corn forty eight
four but that's organic matter makes a
difference here's what it cost me in
1990s to grow this here's a fallow thing
wheat corn fallow wheat corn P it cost
me four sixty that would do weak fallow
379 two wheat corn fallow to forty five
to do wheat corn P people used to ask me
do you make any money on them dang peez
and I said don't make me to make money
on peas I just have to lose less money
than it cost me to summer fell hey I
used to love doing that to people we ran
that study out in Lyman County for
twelve years and in the thirteenth year
I put the whole thing in the spring
wheat and I've shown a lot of over the
years showing a lot of weed things from
there I've never shown you this yield
2002 really dry year right where we
where we did week can all this all went
to spring wheat so where we done wheat
canola for twelve years and then planted
spring wheat there fifteen point four
where did wheat fallow we got twenty
point seven that was on fallow ground
we're just
doing the measured the ones were wheat
would have normally gone wheat corn
fallow 23-7 wheat corn pea 25/8
the interesting thing there this is a
really dry year why is this wheat better
than this week organic matter 12 years
of organic matter we had that one year
when we were producing at least peas
instead of a zero it's an organic matter
thing who says going to talk about
grazing I took this picture at
Lloydminster Saskatchewan how many
people have been to Lloydminster less
people in the bend of Chicago even John
we really don't know where the hell
anything is in Illinois Indiana it's
just over east right we don't have a
clue or any of them things are but you
talk about these towns there we don't
know where they're at
that Lloydminster sits right on the
border of alberta and saskatchewan east
of edmonton which is about five or six
or seven hours north of the border long
ways north grow a lot of corn there and
they graze it in the wintertime so I
took this like in January there's a cow
there in case you guys really can't see
there's a cow hiding and this guy's over
here can't see it that cows hard to see
that's one of the best things you can do
is in Canada is they can't really grow
corn for corn but they can grow it as a
grazer
and they had to do a lot of grazing
because of BSE mad cow and I don't know
how many years ago it was maybe ten
years ago I didn't meet a whole swing up
through northern Canada or north central
Canada Saskatchewan Alberta and I'm
listening to the radio and old cow was
worth seven cents or eight cents a pound
because you couldn't do anything with
them other than make them into dog food
they had to take a bunch of money out of
their cow raising system and they did it
by
quittin hey you know quitting doing
hauling stuff and feeding the college
they put him put them out these are
Canadian cows okay and I'm going to give
you a link later on but if you miss it
just google Alberta swath grazing
Alberta Bale grazing and get all these
videos and these guys talk about how
they do their different different things
it's really interesting
why are we doing this and Jay talked
about a little bit in so did Lance and
dry or brittle environments and soil
biology slows during times of low soil
moisture that would be western central
and western South Dakota the rumen of
grazing animals remains moist continuing
the biological process when it normally
would stop similarly in cold climates
soil biology slows during times of low
soil temperatures and Lance brought that
up talked about the tundra that you
realize the tundra is a hundred miles
north of here right Bruce grew up in
Winnipeg which is several hundred miles
north in here and I didn't see any
Tundra still looking for the polar bears
when we go up to visit the family but
the rumen of grazing animals remains
warm during these times so that's why
this winter grazing thing like Jay said
is is really probably a pretty good
thing so here some of our cover crop
that's of X votes and peas and if in a
little bit of rapeseed growing after we
harvest going to corn okay this is our
mix it's not real fancy we just swap it
we swath it because if you don't swap it
it gets too mature your weight tell us
about right and your swath it otherwise
it goes to hell in terms of all quantity
and quality okay and there it is it
looks like that nice big swath right
there it look nice and green
if you don't swap it on time
you get less stuff and less quality to
sloth on time that where we did it right
we had for a little over 4 tons of stuff
20% protein very good feed oats peas and
rape where we're going to go from weak
to soybeans then we use a mix of oats
German millet and brown midrib for
exordium Sudan and it doesn't grow late
in the fall so didn't yield us as much
in terms of tons or it's not as good of
quality either but it's not opportunity
and then we use a moving fence now you
move it by hand and there's lots of
people know how to do that and that's
fine we decided to do that most of us we
did on our irrigated ground we use our
irrigator to move the fence so that's a
rope hanging down from the irrigator
we've got three of them for span there's
a post and a wire up here and a wire
down here and a bucket to keep things
from blowing around and I do have videos
of this but I'm not going to show it cuz
I don't have time but we just move it
every day or two and then the cows
follow right behind in the movie it
shows them running at a dead run as soon
as they hear the irrigator going they
just come there's a goat dad's moving
the irrigator right so there they line
up and they graze here the day before
and that was a day before that you can
see behind this but they clean up those
swaths all the way down to the ground
but it's nice and uniform see there's
that fence and the irrigator it's a
whole lot nicer to go out when it's 20
below zero and push a button then it is
to go you know drilling holes and doing
whatever so not even when it's cold it's
you know the irrigator doesn't like it
sometimes those contactors are kind of a
little hard to get them to kick in and
stuff but if you do it right the manures
nice you know that 100 and some bushel
wheat that we had is right there is that
straw they never touched that and then
this is the oats stuff now we were
drilling most of this we had had it so
we we also do in corn stocks at the same
time so we could balance their diet with
moving the core
pivot and the oats pivot so they got a
nice balanced diet there's a hay millet
stuff and then we swath that it doesn't
look as good but it's okay the nice
thing about swath grazing if you just
leave the cover crop stand there and
gets jumped full of snow they can't eat
it but if you get it in a swath like
that they will eat it if you go to that
Alberta thing they'll talk about that
mean they got them out and stuff this
deep and the college is going oh there's
a swath under here right but if it's
just they're trying to have to stick
their nose through it all the time but
if they can get their nose on the end of
that sloth they just keep pushing it
with their head and going ahead it's
kind of interesting watch and see here
this is this is them eating through the
snow because we had quite a bit of snow
at time this year there's a fence right
across here this wasn't an irrigator is
actually a fence you can see where the
fence is and right there it's you know
the swath and they know that the swath
goes on goes on ahead they're the
buckets worked better than five gallon
buckets worked better than then the
little tubs but now here we're doing a
thing what we we want to do is plant
earlier so we're working with the thing
with the buffett you know Howard Buffett
gave us some money and told us do
whatever we want to do with it which is
kind of nice you know but but we're
trying to if we can get that cover crop
to start consistently before we harvest
the present crop then it's a win because
we pick up time and and and we don't
have the weed problems and we get extra
time and and so we're looking at at at
seed coatings and we we flew at
Gettysburg we flew in this area
John O'Connell from Letcher flew a bunch
of stuff in this area around Mitchell
and I've got a lot of pictures from from
Gettysburg but not from from John but
here we're flying at Gettysburg there's
a seed the coated seed on the ground we
looked at seed with with just a coating
on it none of this had peat or anything
which I think we're going to need to do
it's just a limestone coating with
absorbent or without absorbent but you
can see the seed the seed grew better
when it was on where it had residue
there so just run through a few this is
field one there seed with with nothing
what we had out there is Indian Head
lentils forage peas and flax so if you
see grass there it doesn't count
so there's bear seed there's where we
had 50% coating with no absorbent on it
and there's more there with absorbent
there's even more it's kind of hard to
tell there but if you take a picture
like that that's what that looked like
and and that's the bare seat equivalent
there was was half 50% so b7 half pounds
of lentils 14 pounds of peas and and 6
pounds of flax ok so the same as the
same seeding rate and all of them and
then we did a thing that we called
winter that was a spring this is winter
levels winter piece and flax versus not
winter flax but the same this is 50%
again saying was that bear seed
basically but it's using winter species
so again the seven and a half and
fourteen and and six and the winters
don't take off as fast as the springs
because they're going well it's going to
be winter and then I'll rest and then
I'll come back next spring right it's
like winter wheat versus oats winter
wheat it'll just lay there and kind of
go oh okay
and then take off the next frame whereas
oats goes it's spring even though it
doesn't know it's August it goes it's
bringing in the dissin and way it goes
and the heads out and okay so there's
that looking down the row okay and then
we we say we we do a winter it's the
same winter things plus we added a few
extra seeing rapeseed and oats so we put
the winter lentil winter pea flax
rapeseed notes these are all going to go
to to two-week to spring so we didn't
want any winter wheat or anything like
in there and that's a bit better because
you got the oats and things trying to do
some things for you and that's what it
looks like down the road okay and that's
just that's just the 50 percent with no
absorbent here's the 50 percent with
absorbent looking down the road that's a
bit thicker now not all the time has the
absorbent helped us sometimes it doesn't
help but in this case it helped us and
there there's another one with absorbent
and then here we go
70% 70% coating with no absorbent wasn't
all that flash and then filled one I
showed you this picture before
here's field one there's a 50 percent
zero and then filled for 50 percent zero
this is a different field that one
didn't they were about three miles apart
okay so it's not consistent enough and
then again field one with the absorbent
on it field for with absorbent again
it's a little better but it will see the
spring what it looks like
here's that thing I told you about but
just Google Alberta swath grazing
whatever more cows more goats more sheep
that's how we're going to feed all these
people a number one meat eat and in the
world is goat okay just so all you
Cowboys get get humbled a bit 100%
grass-fed ground beef this is done in
Aberdeen a guy buys cattle from Montana
coal cows puts him on cover crops at
Aberdeen and he has them as certified
grass-fed somebody bought off on that
okay use a perennial sequence or
perennial cover crops will probably be
necessary we're not going to fix the
salinity thing without perennials and I
think Jay talked about that right day
I'm sound good thing Jay took care
easy work so I just put in one slide yet
all tillage tools destroy soil structure
all til he still has decreased water
infiltration all tillage tools reduce
organic matter and all till these twos
increase weeks right and all these years
that I've come here showed you every one
of those sinks all the data behind it so
I just put that in so you don't get
confused as you drive back by the
machinery dealership when you leave
bureaucracies got reminds corporations
are operated by people of limited tenure
some are more limited than others right
but they're not going to be here long
society and landowners and farmers
deserve to have long term research so it
Dakota Lakes does farmers and ranchers
harvest sunlight carbon dioxide and
water produce products they can sell
some of this is human food we need to be
aware of nutrition issues and off-site
impact so if we want to eat meat maybe
we should contrary in producing meat we
have a new director the West River AG
Center Rapid City you know that's where
we kind of house all the cowboys and
stuff for the West River thing and when
we were interviewing the candidates I
asked the question do you think there'll
be feed Lots in 40 years do you think
about that with all the energy it takes
and all the problems with biological
resistance and all the issues with
nutrient cycling and all these issues
and one of the candidates answered no
the other one went probably not so how
do we start preparing for that tillage
is agriculture where fracking is -
petroleum tying in with Jays thing this
morning
they both increase the speed and extent
of nutrient removal from a resource
leaving the resource degraded in mining
that's what we want to do that's what
grandfather did we can't do that anymore
so we need to quit frackie our soils and
start building our soils
tenuous low disturbance no-till in
combination with diverse rotations and
cover crops is a biological answer to a
biological problem doing the right thing
environmentally is almost always a crack
to have economic approach in the long
run take the out of e tea and the tea
out of cat thank you
[Applause]
you